welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are launching a new series called
protecting the planet which explores
environmental challenges and Solutions
in a changing climate
and today is the federal deadline for
seven western states to provide plans
plans to reduce the amount of water they
take from the dwindling Colorado River
which has to supply 40 million people
historic drought fueled by climate
change and overuse of the river has
drained its reservoirs to record lows
and that is turning water in the west
into a very hot commodity in partnership
with the Weather Channel senior National
and environmental correspondent Ben
Tracy shows us how Wall Street now sees
dollar signs in the drought Ben I don't
like the sound of that good morning
yeah this is a tough one good morning
Tony we are talking potentially billions
of dollars at stake and that's because
the Colorado River is one of the most
valuable economic resources in the
United States and despite a wet winter
so far here in the west the river system
is still in crisis and now private
investors are betting that in a hotter
and drier future water is the new oil
Joe bernal's family has lived on the
western slope of the Rockies for nearly
100 years come on back
foreign
he raises cattle and grows crops on more
than 500 acres of land near Grand
Junction Colorado
your main source of water is the
Colorado
our only source of water is the Colorado
so that river is your lifeline that's it
that's all we got with is that River and
that river is why someone new bought the
land just down the road from his Ranch
Water Asset Management owns that
property and when you first heard of
them what was your reaction surprise and
concerned they are concerning because
they're large water asset management is
a Wall Street investment firm with
offices inside this building in New York
City CBS News has learned that in the
past five years the company has bought
at least 20 million dollars worth of
land in western Colorado investors in a
manhattan-based firm are now one of the
largest landowners in the Grand Valley I
assume they wouldn't be here if they
didn't think there was a lot of money to
be made I think that's a logical
assumption does that worry you
of course it worries us what do
investors in New York want with land
here in Colorado I don't think they want
much with the land it's the water right
Andy Mueller is general manager of the
Colorado River District created by the
state to protect its share of Colorado
River water
in Colorado water in the west is is your
future without water you have no future
Mueller says water Asset Management has
acquired at least 2500 acres of land for
the water rights that come with it he
calls them speculators betting that as
the West gets drier those with water
rights will get richer these are folks
that have identified the drought as an
opportunity to make money I view these
private drought profiteers as vultures
that's pretty strong yeah they're
looking to make a lot of money off this
public resource it's a trillion dollar
market opportunity Matt deserio is
President and co-founder of water Asset
Management he declined our repeated
requests for an interview we basically
acquire here very specific water rights
but in an interview three years ago with
fintech disario explicitly said that one
of his firm strategies is to profit from
water in part by making the Farm's
advise more efficient and then selling
parts of its water rights to other
farmers and cities increasingly
desperate for this essential resource
when you need water water is the only
thing that will do water Asset
Management even hired Colorado's former
top water official James Eckland as a
lawyer and the company's website states
that scarce clean water is the resource
defining this Century much like
plentiful oil Define the last so why is
water now so scarce in the west well Dr
Greg Postell with our partners at the
weather channel is here to explain well
the Colorado River relies mainly on the
snowpack from the Rocky Mountains that
feeds into the river as it melts during
the Spring and Summer but climate change
is making the West hotter and for every
degree in increase in temperature we see
that corresponds to about a five percent
reduction in the river flow so over the
last century we've seen roughly a 20
reduction overall and then on top of
that you have this 23 year long Mega
drought in the west the worst in 1200
years and there's also overuse of this
River by a lot of Western States yeah
that's right and it's taking a toll on
the nation's largest reservoirs Lake
Mead in Nevada and Lake Powell in
Arizona they're at about 25 percent of
their combined full capacity and there
are real fears that this crucial water
supply for the West is on the brink of
disaster and that is a problem for
people all over the West including
ranchers high in the Colorado Rockies
all right who owns this one Rancher
Carrie Donovan is a former Colorado
state senator she's alarmed by the
amount of land being bought by investors
for water rights scarcity does equal
value right she tried to make Colorado's
anti-speculation laws stronger but that
effort failed Colorado has pretty strong
laws on this you can't move water out of
state you have to use it for a
beneficial use so how do they make money
on this they'll probably make money
because the state will be forced to
create a system that doesn't exist right
now to allow more flexibility and how a
water ride is used so these private
investors may not be buying this under
the rules that exist today but this
might be a long-term play yeah I think
you're exactly right in fact if you look
at their website they even presented as
such as the Arid West gets more
desperate the federal government is
expected to make sure the Taps keep
flowing in cities including Denver Las
Vegas Phoenix in Los Angeles Congress
recently allocated four billion dollars
in drought funding that can be used to
pay Farmers to follow their land and not
use their water some Western States
including Colorado are also considering
payment plans and those dollars get
pretty big pretty fast and if you're
sitting on water rights that's just free
money yeah I mean who is going to
benefit most from a following concept an
investment firm that's not too concerned
if the ground that they own is Farm to
ranched so whose land is this water
asset management and now this Rancher's
future is tied to Wall Street some of
the land Joe Bernal now Farms is leased
to him by water Asset Management it's
what kind of landlord have they been so
far so good but he says ranchers here in
the Grand Valley
are keeping an eye on their new
neighbors from New York good stewards of
the land and stewards of the water
rights will have their eyes open and
we'll be watching for what what may be
coming
now water asset management is not the
only firm looking to buy water rights in
the west but local officials tell us it
is one of the most aggressive now as for
that Federal deadline today for western
states to propose cuts to their water
supplies six of the states have issued a
plan for cuts but California which draws
the largest share of the river is so far
not on board the federal government may
have to impose cuts which will likely
end up in court eight courts are very of
course are very busy these days Ben it's
very eye-opening report water is a new
oil you said at the top reminds you that
seeming The Lorax when they start
selling fresh air except this is real
life very troubling stuff appreciate it
a lot at stake